all the logic that we're seeing in the
net neutrality debate is assuming that
nothing has changed it's assuming it's
1995 I am Nicolas booth recent TV and
today we're talking with Dan Berninger
he's the head of VC XE which is trying
to speed up the transition to an all IP
information and called Network Dan
thanks for talking to us no problem
the FCC are the head of the FCC has just
come out in favor of taking title to
regulations and applying it to the
Internet in the name of net neutrality
what is wrong with title 2 regulations
which govern or have govern for decades
old-style telephone networks why
shouldn't that be applied to the right
internet so title 2 regulation has been
around for 80 years we know exactly what
it can accomplish and what it can
accomplish and and as we as we watched
it over those 80 years it all the things
that it touched it essentially destroyed
innovation so the regulated services
essentially have no more customers and
and basically this transition started in
1995 and by that you mean just kind of
old-style landlines oh right old-style
landline phones essentially have lost
all their customers because people have
communication alternatives and I'm
including Skype in that so it might be
voice that just doesn't run over the
traditional network and so I mean
there's reasons why that happens in the
sense in in title 2 world where the FCC
is essentially the product manager for
your service you first and foremost have
to get the FCC's approval on what you're
doing and that you can only serve one
boss and so that kind of crowds out
everything else now you know of course
Tom wheeler the current FCC head as well
as his predecessor Julius Genachowski
who had tried something similar talked
about well you know we're going to have
title to regulation in our back pocket
but we're gonna use a light touch or
we're gonna forbear we're not we're not
actually going to implement this stuff
why shouldn't we believe them when they
when they talk that way right so the
reason we got to where we are is because
it wasn't a question of light touch or
Barents it was there was a legal
definition that said title 2 is
regulated this way and the FCC has these
powers and there's something called an
information service that is is not
regulated at all and that trace that
traces back to the consent decree with
AT&T and the 56 so in 1956 we split
communication and computing and treated
them entirely different sort of it I
mean essentially as a twin experiment
you can think bring it forward well
guess what one twin prospered and one
twin did not do very well and so the the
twin that prospered essentially washed
over and took everything that the old
twin was doing basically communications
and so we get to this point in 2015 that
other twin has nothing to do anymore is
just twiddling his fingers on the other
hand he has you know that network is
still there all that copper or that
switch is still collecting electricity
but it doesn't have any customers and so
the question is at that at that moment
in time do you take the rules that led
the the twin that failed and apply them
to the twin that was successful and
you're not buying it then that the FCC
will you know what we have title to but
we're not going to use it it's just
there to make sure that the you know
ISPs and the telcos who are connecting
people to the Internet
are not you know they're not blocking
certain sites they're not screwing
around with things right so the first
decision all the entrepreneurs like
myself make you know when you have an
idea the first thing you ask yourself is
this regulated is this a regulated
industry and the praat in the old world
you know before where we're going with
the FCC here I knew if I was doing it on
the internet and if and if I had like
two services that were internet services
and I combined them I had an internet
service and I was unregulated what's
changing now is that line is going away
with the FCC is saying oh it's it's all
telecom it's all telecom regulations and
so now it entrepreneur actually don't
won't know they're not we're gonna have
to pick up the phone call a regulatory
attorney well I'm doing this what's the
risk that the FCC would get this
attention and the attorney will give
them some risk assessment and and then
they'll get really big and then well
well then we'll have to start an FCC
proceeding about it
the the net neutrality proceeding is how
the FCC works it takes ten years to make
a decision I think the average decision
time is like six years from start to
finish and so that's a problem for an
entrepreneur so essentially what that
means is I mean as it is there is not in
Silicon Valley there are not that many
sort of telecom ish activities for that
reason if this happens then then it goes
away completely so you know one of the
big fears you know or one of the reasons
why net neutrality has become popular is
partly because it's kind of difficult to
decide or to define it's kind of in the
you know it people say I want net
neutrality meaning they want the
Internet that they have now yeah
and that they you know are comfortable
with is that why is that short-sighted
well so net neutrality assumes sort of a
zero sum nothing changes view of the
world so when the originator wrote the
paper Tim Wu and 2002 he had tables in
there showing we got to protect how
you're using your one mag right so in
2002 20% of the population had one Meg
and and he threw out his thesis but the
thesis requires that a zero sum that
that you're protecting that one Meg that
never ever changes and so the most
important thing you can have is equal
treatment of all those bits and we're
gonna figure out how to get there
what's actually happened is that people
get more and more surveys year and year
out whether it's wireline or Wireless
and so now you know we're sitting in
wireline world where the average in the
country is 10 Meg and Wireless we just
deployed LTE and so that's essentially a
process that improves the experience
that people have so a part of the idea
with net neutrality that is I mean or
part of the shortsightedness of it you
would say is that it's assuming that
we're always going to have the Internet
we have today right whereas in fact it's
constantly innovative or it has been in
the absence of these rules right why do
you know one of the other arguments a
you know in favor of net neutrality is
that look these ISPs whether it's
Comcast or Time Warner or whoever who
are trying to merge or talking about
merger
they have effective monopolies on that
last mile into your house and so they're
gonna collect big tolls and they're
gonna either say to you hey if you want
to see the websites that you want to see
or the services the streaming services
you want to see you're gonna pay us a
lot more money and then they're gonna go
back to Netflix and say hey if you want
that movie to be seen by your customer
especially if it's competing against
something that Comcast is creating
because Comcast is also NBC you know you
you've got to pay us a lot of money to
get you know to get through that last
mile what's wrong first of all there's
nobody that's against net neutrality
right so there isn't Pro net neutrality
ante net neutrality there's a side that
is Pro net neutrality and make title
tube for the FCC to save it or protect
it and there's a side that says well you
know what net neutrality is taken care
of itself in the network and in the
network in the market and if you
actually assert the FCC in here it's
going to make things worse
and so the question one needs to ask is
there some reason some market reason as
to why somebody would you know the path
to profitability of a network is to
violate net neutrality everywhere and
we'd have to speculate about that
because it hasn't actually happened I
mean the sense that there are obviously
trillions of interactions using the
Internet where are all these violations
and the reason they aren't there is
because really isn't an economic
incentive for an operator to give people
reasons not to use their network even
even if they're in a at least
temporarily monopoly position even if so
you're probably familiar your your
viewers are familiar with something
called Moore's Law in the it was sort of
the driving force of Silicon Valley well
the guys that created that and funded
that were a monopoly
now why did Intel create and fund
Moore's law they had a monopoly on chips
they could have just started charging
people more and more money to use their
chips because when you expand the
capacity of the network when you expand
processing capacity it grows what you
can do with that service and so as the
operators expand the capacity of their
networks it expands the things that the
network's can do and so the value of the
network
is a function of what it can do that's
the path to maximize enterprise value so
I mean what you're saying is that from a
business perspective it makes Comcast
they could do a short plane so okay in
the next six months we're gonna jack up
our rates and we're going to force all
of the content providers to pay us money
to get to people's computer screens but
they actually haven't acted that way as
much as everybody hates Comcast right
they realize that they want to be around
in a couple of years right so you you
would really have to again assume
Moore's law goes away that and Moore's
law drives all the switching equipment
in terms of cost of improvement over
time to do something like that now again
instantaneously at any given moment and
some buddy has a bright idea they will
attempt something but again the the
public is not powerless to you know
raise a voice and say they don't like it
one of the things that people don't take
an account here is is the bar that the
carriers have to meet that as we have
expanded capacity a thousandfold since
1995 in 1995 again where there's 15
million people on the internet we're
doing dial-up 9.6 modems okay so we had
a thousand times more capacity now the
impact of that is that people are super
hyper they're you know about what they
get is their lifeblood right all you
walk through the streets everybody's got
their head down in their screen it's
really really important to them and so
carriers have a very very high threshold
you know in terms of performance and
people will get upset and is there any
reason to believe when you look at the
FCC's own data you know one idea is that
if if a provider has a monopoly they
start to lower service and they start to
raise price do we see that in the data
of you know the number of people who are
connecting to the Internet or the
capacity is that's slowing down and that
is essentially 20th century thinking all
the logic that we're seeing in the net
neutrality debate is assuming that
nothing has changed it's assuming it's
1995 it it's not sort of taking into
account what's happened since 1995
before 1995 it was certainly the case
that if you had a fixed cost Network and
you were delivering the same service for
50 60 years
you would want to sort of match
some eyes your cut of the end-users
payment and you're gonna screw all your
buddies and other companies to get you
Orkut that's not the world we're in now
and so those incentives are not around
all right well we will leave it there
we've been talking with Dan Berninger a
VC XE about title to regulation of the
Internet via the FCC dan thanks so much
thanks for having me